[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es einen wunsch rezept vor
murat er hat sich nämlich ein super
weiches toastbrot rezept gewünscht und
das mache ich jetzt heute das heißt ich
mache es heute einmal weißes toastbrot
und alma vollkornbrot und ich zeige euch
mal die wenigen zutaten die ihr dafür
braucht für den hefeteig nämlich 50
gramm warmes wasser einen halben würfel
hefe einen esslöffel zucker 500 gramm
und da habe ich jetzt in 400 515
teelöffel salz 250 gramm lauwarme milch
und 50 g weiche butter
das nehme ich da ist die hefe die kommt
hier direkt in das warme wasser
gemeinsam mit dem zucker kann ich jetzt
hier kurz verrühren und da gebe ich
jetzt schon mal einen esslöffel mehl
dazu ich mache dir einen vorteig und
denen dass ich jetzt abgedeckt an einem
warmen ort für etwa 15 minuten stehen
und dann sollte die hilfe schon richtig
gut aufgegangen sein
so sollte es jetzt ungefähr aussehen
entweder 15 minuten an einem warmen ort
oder einfach fünf minuten bei der stufe
im dampf backofen geht echt super
schnell und jetzt kann ich einfach alle
zutaten hier eben die rührschüssel geben
ihr könnt den teig natürlich auch mit
der hand verkneten deswegen habe ich
jetzt schon drin
die hilfe kommt jetzt hier noch mit 1
dann noch die milch dazu das salz und
jetzt kann ich den teig schon mal kneten
und gleich noch die butter dazugeben und
die sollte einfach schön weich sein
den teig lasse ich jetzt wird warf fünf
bis sieben minuten lang nähten so
richtig schön glatt ist
so jetzt ist der teig soweit und ich
hätte auch immer ganz gerne meine hände
schöne weichert aber nicht klebrig jetzt
einfach kurz zu einer kugel zusammen
formen und so wie ich jetzt den hier
gemacht habe werde ich jetzt gleich noch
eine vollkommen variante machen
ich nehme das dinkelvollkornbrot zum
vollkornmehl benutzen und dann zeige ich
euch nämlich gleich beide gut so so gebe
ich hier nicht zurück in die schüssel
und fährt ihn noch ein bisschen und kann
ihnen jetzt einfach abgedeckt in der
schüssel hier aufgehen lassen entweder
hier mit hitze oder im dampf backofen
einfach eingestuft oder einfach
beim vollkornbrot hat man nur den
einzigen unterschied dass man einfach
etwas meine milch braucht
ich geb dir jetzt noch 30 gramm mehr
willst dazu und dann passt auch jede
fünfte jetzt der teig schön aufgegangen
jetzt bereite ich ihnen hier einfach so
ein bisschen aus dann nehme ich hier
noch eine kasten backform und hättet ihr
jetzt mit dem spray oder butan das geht
auch jetzt könnt ihr hier den teig
ausrollen dieser rolle lege ich jetzt
hier rein
der streich den teil jetzt hier mit
etwas butter und las dann das brot noch
einmal aufgehen
das heißt so dass es wirklich schön
verdoppelt ist dann geht es nämlich
richtig schön locker habe
ich nehme jetzt für die brote doch eine
etwas kleinere backform habe ich einfach
eine aus glas genommen die es etwas
schmaler und so kann es brot etwas in
die höhe wachsen und nicht in die breite
das weise habe ich auch schon umgesetzt
und jetzt hier auch dieses vollkornbrot
lass es jetzt nochmal richtig schön
aufgehen und dann werden das black pack
jetzt ist der teig schön aufgegangen und
den ofen habe ich auch bereits
vorgehalten so und die kommen jetzt
direkt in den heißen backofen und werden
da gebacken und murat und kündigt die
stehen schon in den startlöchern denn
ihr werdet ihr daraus dann was leckeres
zaubern
und nachdem button werden sie direkt
noch heiß mit butter bestrichen und dann
dürfen sie ein bisschen abkühlen morath
ihr könnt euch bereit machen ja ich bin
bereit ich übergebe dem ein mikrofon
jetzt ist das toastbrot fertig habe es
auch direkt nach dem bug mit butter
bestrichen und abkühlen lassen
ein bisschen warm ist es noch aber wir
schneiden selbst denn murat und unity
wollen gleich weitermachen
murat kommst du dazu zum magischen das
so zart dass brot schmeckt frisches brot
die zas besseres futter mischen sie
nicht belegen sondern nur mit guter öko
test
und vor allem kann man ja auch so die
scheiben schneiden und einfrieren und da
hat man immer frisches toastbrot geben
sagte nicht bedienen sollen schneide ich
noch dass vollkornbrot morath ist guck
mal dass ich auch richtig schön
aufgenommen
also du findest das so vielen das ging
ja wirklich wirklich eines krans nicht
beantworten das ist wie schmeckt so ein
toastbrot einem tag spiele ja das kann
ich dir jetzt nicht beantworten aber
wenn meine scheibe übrig lassen du hast
morgen nach tränen das problem ich
glaube ich dass bis morgen fahren wir
werden es nie erfahren denn morath und
gené machen jetzt aus diesem topf auch
gleich leckere so was wir heute noch
machen für die iss machen so einen
bigmac tost also so ein richtig cooles
rezept mit einem toaster übrigens über
zehn jahre an elf jahre alt 11 jahre elf
jahre alte toaster der war schon im
ersten video genau will ich im
hintergrund links öffnet er mich auf
jeden fall machen wir einen kurs mobil
machen paris uns die penis mal ganz
besonders wir werden die partie ist
nichts mit hackfleisch machen sollten
wir was anderes vor
das sage ich jetzt nicht verraten welche
erst im nächsten jahr kommt wenn es
wieder heißt für orads fünf minuten oder
auch länger oder kroos traut richtig
cool
das hat mich an dieses mal ein roland
erzeugt genau und 2 roland anspruch
genau dieses knaup
das fühlt sich an wie der zertritt mein
bruder könig braucht dann baut sich doch
auch so nach dem prozessverlauf ich
hätte jetzt mein brot
ok ich lass euch ihr dürft jetzt machen
was hier unterhält profi aber zuerst mal
ein paar fotos als er das rezept gibt es
auf celtics - blog.de wie gesagt einmal
die falcon variante einmal der
weissbrodt variante probiert es gerne
mal aus und schreibt mir in die
kommentare genau funktioniert hat wohl
nur einschalten das heißt morath fünf
minuten wir machen im big mac zu
gelangen
und jetzt gesehen es ist super einfach
nur ein bisschen geduld wird und den
kanal können die autos dann nicht